bienvenue dans l'église saint julien de
ban et ses fonts baptismaux et son
confessionnal classe et ses vitraux et
son coeur bien portants ici malades ans
et comble aux charpentes usé par des
décennies on le voit avec l'absence des
tenons mortaises sur les parties cintrée
de chaque côté on a aussi on voit bien
les cerclages métallique qui ont été
faits il ya 80 ou 100 ans pour tenir
justement les assemblages et ça il faut
que ça soit remplacé et toute la toiture
va être complètement refaite à neuf pour
financer les 36000 euros de rénovation
la commune a lancé un appel aux dons en
partenariat avec la fondation du
patrimoine
ce projet le moyen d'impliquer les
habitants dans une aventure commune
on met en place un bon de souscription
ou savez comment ça fonctionne vous
pouvez faire un don
voyez je fais don de telles sommes vous
mettez votre nom votre adresse si vous
avez mlc déductibles des impôts
1000 bons de souscription viennent
d'être imprimé faut solliciter les
administrés mais aussi le contacter et
envoyer un bulletin de souscription à
toutes les entreprises du secteur qui en
particulier aux entreprises qu'ils iront
travailler pour la commune lors d'appels
d'offres ou lors de travaux des concerts
dans l'église était pièces de théâtre
seront également proposés l'occasion de
créer du lien social et de multiplier
les recettes car plus la commune lève de
fonds plus la subvention sera élevé la
commune de banne elle doit recueillir au
minimum 3200 euros et au delà chaque
euros recueillis sur le demain de
manière supplémentaire donnera lieu à
une subvention d'un euro en plus et ça
marche
on a dans toutes les souscriptions qu'on
a organisées dans le cher on a toujours
obtenu ce seuil minimum qui a donc
déclenché la subvention qui était prévu
dans le cher 61 sites bénéficient de
cette subvention
plus de 300 en région centre val de
loire